the crops have withered
the grass has turned to dust
and the animals that support millions
are dying
where seasonal rains brought life to the
borderlands of ethiopia somalia and
kenya
bone dry winds now blow
it hasn't rained here for three years
most people here are pastoralists they
follow their animals and live from the
land
but the shortage of water has driven
many into camps
thousands live here in this ad hoc
settlement in ethiopia
and the aid agencies are struggling to
feed them
the un says 13 million are facing severe
hunger
others still crisscross the territory
searching for water if their livestock
can manage it
but if the animals die malnutrition
typically follows for they are the only
source of meat and milk
unicef says hundreds of thousands of
children are now at risk of severe
malnutrition what will happen in your
view if we don't get
significant rainfall
in april
oh god no this year i mean
it is a possibility
which i would not like even to think of
but i mean professionally i have to
and i think
it can be a real catastrophe a huge
catastrophe
in somalia the drought has been
particularly fierce 90 percent of the
country has been affected and many have
abandoned their homes in search of food
and water
aid agencies say there is still time to
act but the lives of millions are at
risk
john sparks sky news